hello everyone this next game was
suggested to me again by a subscriber
and at first when I saw who played the
game I didn't know the game he was
talking about but as soon as I reached
the critical position of the game I
immediately remembered which game it was
because I saw this game plenty of times
and I seen this I've seen the critical
position I also have it in my book
strategy and tactics bye-bye listen and
as soon as I saw it was this game I was
I was very happy so this is the game I
decided to show you and the game was
played in 1938 and there was this Dutch
radio company called a bro and they
decided to organize and sponsor the
strongest chess tournament ever held so
they got together a couple of very
strong players for example Paul Karras
Ruben fine Mikhail Botvinnik Alexandra
Ji Heon max you josé raúl capablanca
Samuel Reshevsky and Solomon floor and
well bifida standards it was the
strongest tournament ever held to that
date and well Paul Karras won the
tournament tied with Reuben fine and
Mikhail Botvinnik actually got third
place and this is well somewhat young
gimmick about winning he was 27 years
old here and this is ten years before
Mikhail Botvinnik actually want his
championship title and at the at the
time that this game was played
Alexander Radian was the the reigning
world champion so it was a very you know
a very strong tournament and the game I
decided to show you is Mikhail Botvinnik
versus Jose roll kappa blanka so well
without further ado let's check the game
out
we have d4 by botanique Knight to f6 by
capablanca c4 e6 we have Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 the nimzo-indian
defense we have III d5 a three Bishop
captures and c3b captures on c3 and c5
and this is all standard theory so we
have seek after sandy 5e captors and e5
n bishop
three developing that bishop and a nice
square we have castles Knight to e2 b6
preparing to develop botany castles and
now Bishop to a6 so Bishop captures on
a6 Knight captures an a6 and the bishop
the b2 so Queen to d7 and now a four we
have rook F to e8 Queen to d3 attacking
that night on a six c4 and Queen to c2
and if you look at this position it
seems like well this dark square Bishop
bought me hasn't be - it seems like a
pretty useless piece but in the future
it can very easily go to a3 and go to
this strong diagonal or even maybe c1
and then after he pushes d4 maybe to g5
or f4 so although it is a bad piece now
it does have a lot of potential so
Capablanca plays Knights to be eight and
he plays this move with the idea of
playing Knight to c6 285 and then to be
three and this would be a very strong
square for the knight so we have rook a
to e1 and kappa blanka continues with
his plan and Knight to c6 Knight to g6
by bothwick Knight to a5 f3 so but when
he prepares this plan of f3 + d 4 +
kappa blanka plays in Knight to b3 and
now by playing this Knight to b3 moved
here he's also attacking this a for pawn
because both eunuchs queen isn't
protecting it anymore
but the but when he can actually
sacrifices this point in place efore so
as there's really no immediate threat
capablanca always elects to capture a
pawn so he plays Queen captures an a4 we
have E 5 kicking that night Knight to d7
and now Queen 2 F 2 preparing f4 and f5
we have g6 by kappa blanka and now f4
and well here Botvinnik is threatening
f5 and if he manages to play this well
white would be what would be somewhat
better here and this would be very hard
to play for 4 kappa blanka so he decides
to push f5 himself and what when he
captures he captures an f6 Knight
captures an f6 and now well still pushes
F
five so we have rook captures any one
rook captures anyone and now rook to e8
and botany plays rook to e6 now
attacking that night so cover bunker
captures with the rook we have F
captures only six and I'll kink the g7
protecting the night we have Queen to f4
and now the queen is threatening to
infiltrate the c7 here so capablanca
decides to bring his own queen to help
out with the defense and plays Queen to
e8 we have Queen to e5 pinning that
night Queen to e7 and this is the
critical position when I was looking
looking this game and I immediately
remembered the game and well this is one
of those position where the the engine
actually isn't suggesting the move that
what winning played even though it is
the strongest move in the position the
computer is suggesting something like h4
which doesn't really do anything
immediately
but what Botvinnik played is well
nothing short of spectacular
and if you would like feel free to pause
the video and try to find a move for
yourself okay I will give it a couple of
seconds for you to do it if you want to
okay well if you did find the moved and
what congratulations to you your you're
an amazing player and if you didn't and
you would still like to know what
Botvinnik played botanique played Bishop
to a3 and at first the computer totally
doesn't like this move he thinks this is
a draw but you'll see why it's not so
kappa blanka captures the bishop as well
the Queen doesn't really have that many
options she has to kind of protect this
epon from being pushed and well he kept
he captures it and now another fancy
move by both me he plays Knight to h5
check and well the knight cannot capture
it and well Botvinnik is now threatening
to capture this knight on f6 as he's
attacked by the Queen in the night so
only move is G captures on h5 and now
Botvinnik plays Queen to g5 check and
this is the
well the king only the King can go only
to f/8 and to h8 and wherever the King
goes a couple of automatic will capture
this night with check so couple Bhangra
plays King to f8 we have Queen captures
and f6 with check and now King to g8 and
Botvinnik simply pushes East 7 preparing
a e8 with queening and mating and this
is probably the position why why the
engine didn't like that bishop date
remove it was probably too hard for the
engine to calculate that bishop date
remove and now to calculate all the
checks that black Queen can give to this
white King but for a human player this
is somewhat easier as well you know
human brain does does use patterns and
well I'm pretty sure Botvinnik was
completely sure that this is winning so
kappa blanka plays Queen to c1 check we
have king to f2 Queen to c2 check King
to g3 twin to d3 check
Oh King to H 424 chair and now King
captures on h5 Queen to e2 check
and now King to h4 and now again Queen
to e4 check but now what we need since
he already captured that h5 point can
play g4 so kappa blanka play is going to
be one check and now King to h5 and in
this position because they roll kappa
banker resigned and there are no more
checks in the position although as
sometimes I say say in my videos that
there are no more no more checks in the
position and then someone says oh what
do you mean there were checks in the
position but what actually meant was
well there are no more meaningful checks
you know those those kinds of checks
that actually do accomplish something
but I really do believe that in this
position there are no more checks
except for maybe Queen to h4 check but
this is well ridiculous so yeah in this
position Jose broke up among ko resigned
and a very nice victory for young
Botvinnik
and yeah like I said it was it was the
strongest tournament so far it was
played in November 1938 and both
Minik one a very strong third place and
it's interesting that first place was
won by Polaris with eight and a half
points and also Reuben fine got eight
and a half points both week was third
and then after the three of them the
three world champions got the rest of
the places so yeah a very nice very nice
showing by all of them especially Paul
Karras but we'll we'll deal with
Karissa's game some other time so yeah
and this is the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said I'm pretty sure
this critical position with the Bishop
III move can be found in a lot of books
so maybe you've seen this game maybe
haven't if you haven't it's a very nice
game to see and yeah that's it
I do hope you really enjoyed it and as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and yeah before I forget I
would I would like to thank Johanna
Akhtar a thank you for your contribution
to my channel I do appreciate it and
that's it thank you for watching and I
will see you soon